what's a trustworthy name Sara Margaret
oh yeah yeah I trust Emily's are like
girls names that are guy names like
Samantha looks Sam Sam's are like
down-to-earth like they wear the
baseball cap and they're like cool like
they're like Samantha's on the other
hand Samantha's definitely a princess
did you like princesses love Jessa's or
like a good friend there are always down
I think you're great at this yes yes
ACCA's and Lauren's are good friends
yeah yes cousin Lauren's are always a
pair really well
I feel like Jessica's are some of the
sweetest girls I know Jessica's army
Jessie's immediately are a different
person they're the kind of people that
literally offer you candy when you see
this they're like oh I have so much
candy you want some candy always carry
Bianca no be on Bianca's a red flag
named red flag maybe or her friends
collar
B I think the craziest name is Britney
brims have a big range Sophie is crazy
yeah Sophie's are great yes so these are
not he's the type of chick that'll like
break a bottle like oh it's volatile
that's but it's exciting Jacqueline you
can't control a Jacqueline Jacqueline is
like blonde and like ready to yell
Becky's a freak she's Becky's a freak
Rebecca's are in charge of Becky his
Becky's drunk and everyone's like oh
it's just Becky Rebecca that's an uber
Oh Christina's tollerance teen is a
total milf young would meet a MILF named
Brandon when Brenda is younger is that
weird face but when Brenda gets to be a
mom it's hot that's like pink brenda ton
AMI
let your mom's name is Amy Alice would
be a MILF name for sure I'm mrs. Johnson
don't call me mrs. Johnson call me Alice
oh yeah that would get me Alice you like
Oh Alice you're so crazy
hahaha Meagan would probably like be in
charge meg also be in charge
Olivia's our leader Olivia's are like
powerful like powerhouse women if you
like Olivia's are smart yeah I feel like
Olivia's are very smart
Olivia's are perfect I kind of feel like
Jayde is kind of power Jade Maria could
be like a real Maria could totally be
about Maria Gutierrez is my boss Gwen
but Gwen's are in charge sometimes when
sounds like someone who could be in
charge but also very sexy like Authority
is sexy abs a hot girl
like Lexi Lexi I think endless are hot
because they got that southern sweet
thing it's like a short little em'ly and
it's like Oh something like Sasha you
know it's about Sasha right I'm not even
my black dress quarter-latino yeah very
elegant but she's not snobby sauce
Alexandra's intimate a likes and garlic
see there's this like a powerful
sexuality alexandra is in a ballroom
right now
Taylor's one of those girl boy names
across the board men and women they're
good-looking people guaranteed if you
want your kid to look good name it
Taylor we're like Nicole I think Nicole
is like a really hot name Nicky and
Nicole are both hot the difference is
Nikki will burn your clothes in the
front yard when you break up with her
that's a black Nikki that's a black and
if you definitely I know that Nikki
Oh